et nouveau rassemblement du monde de la
culture aujourd'hui à paris artistes
techniciens et intermittents du
spectacle tous dénoncent la situation
précaire dans laquelle il se trouve
depuis un an maintenant rassemblés
devant le théâtre de l'odéon ces
derniers exigent la réouverture des
lieux culturels et pointe du doigt la
gestion de la crise sanitaire par le
gouvernement un des politiques se sont
également joints à la manifestation je
vous propose de les écouter
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la france elle
est minée par la dépression quand on
regarde les statistiques de france santé
publique
c'est un français sur trois qui se
disent en dépression un jeune sur deux
qui sont inquiets pour leur santé
mentale et qu'est ce qu'on va comment on
va résoudre ça est-ce qu'on va résultats
en donnant des cachets à tout le monde
est ce qu'on va voir tout ça en disant
aux gens restés devant vos écrans
où est ce qu'on va avoir de la joie à
transmettre dans le pays
ce printemps cet été on ne peut pas
considérer la culture comme accessoires
et on a besoin de soutenir et développer
encore la culture et en particulier
soutenir celles et ceux qui la font
vivre
la ministre de la culture a brillé par
son absence et donc et par son peu
d'engagement en soutien au monde de la
culture est donc je comprends c'est que
les les responsables qui joue un peu
leur vie finalement on parle de 800
mille personnes qui risquent de basculer
dans la précarité la plus complète
mais non il ya urgence et qui veulent
pas parler aux personnes qui ne compte
pas aujourd'hui c'est une décision qui
est dans les mains du premier ministre
du président de la république
la culture est essentielle et on doit
soutenir celles et ceux qui la font dire